mais d'abord sa première mission
écologique et son bilan au ministère du
même nom avec flora sauvage à peine
nommée première ministre elisabeth baume
la firme l'environnement sera au coeur
de sa mission je pense aux défis
climatiques et écologiques sur le cas il
faut agir plus vite et plus fort
pourtant celle qui a passé un an à la
tête du ministère de la transition
écologique de l'été 2010 9 à l'été 2000
banque ne suscite guère l'enthousiasmé
chez les verts pour le patron des
sénateurs écologistes
beaucoup de temps a été perdu on a aussi
à son actif le report de dix ans de la
diminution du nucléaire et du passage à
50% après il ya eu aussi le report de
l'interdiction du glyphosate femme
elisabeth borgne a aussi apporté des
bonnes nouvelles
huit ans elle était en charge de
l'écologie avec l'abandon du projet euro
facility parsèment la création des zones
à faibles émissions peut-être à son
actif je dirais etc et c'est d'ailleurs
assez révélateur c'est la loi des cta
loi sur l'économie circulaire qui était
effectivement qui effectivement je
trouve un texte intéressante peut-être
aussi quand même à son actif le plan
vélo même si on attendait d
des finances supplémentaires en face à
l'urgence climatique
elisabeth bornes doit mettre en oeuvre
la promesse du président de la
république la planification écologique
rattaché à matignon sinon si la fin du
grand ministère de la transition
écologique le ministère de l'impossible
selon robert poujade le premier ministre
en charge de l'environnement en 1971
les premiers pas d isabelle borne à
matignon avec mes invités laure salvaing
bonsoir vous êtes directrice générale de
kantar public france denis olivennes
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi patron de
presse essayiste auteur d'un étrange
relancement publié aux éditions albin
michel j'accueille également benjamin
morel bon ça arrive bien ni maître de
conférences en droit public à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas et
lætitia cru pas éditorialiste politique
bonsoir letizia avant de parler de cette
mission cette planification écologique
peut-être votre analyse aux uns et aux
autres sur cette nomination pour
commencer alors ça va un constat ils
avaient deux bornes a beau être ministre
depuis cinq ans il ya beaucoup de
français qui la découvrent de plusieurs
alors qu'il ya des courbes pas tout à
fait mais c'est vrai qu'elle fait partie
de ses ministres j'avais envie dire un
peu comme tous les ministres du premier
mandat à maquereau qui sont très discret
il ya très peu de ministres qui ont
vraiment émergé pendant cette mandature
et effectivement elle est plutôt
considérée par les français comme ceux
qui la connaissent comme une femme
travailleuse discrète qui n'a pas de
casseroles et c'est une technicienne
quelque part encore connu mais
finalement pas
kiki qu'en dire qu'il reste quand même
très crédible aux yeux de l'opinion et
on en parlera de oui oui avec notamment
une cote d'avenir qui est intéressant
devenue la la présenterait alors si je
résume évidemment c'est très très
caricatural une bosseuse qui maîtrise
ses sujets qui ne cherchent pas
forcément la lumière les coups
médiatiques de new dance est parfait
pour emmanuel macron oui mais je crois
qu'elle est le coche les cases quand
vous y réfléchissez à vos bons on a on
est nous on est grognon quand même c'est
là que il suffit que quelqu'un émerge
dans le paysage pour que tout de suite
s'ils se prennent les boules de son du
chamboule tout donc les gens de droite
la troupe de gauche et jean gauche qui
la trouvent de droite enfin bref elle
est là y a plus d'état de grâce à l'
état de disgrâce ou quelques secondes
vous êtes déjà contestés avant même on
pourrait quand même lui laisser le
bénéfice du doute et puis par ailleurs
quand on regarde théoriquement enfin sur
le
son sont sa feuille de score
elle est compétente
indiscutablement à la fédé école
remarquable et meilleures écoles
françaises oui elle est expérimentée
avec les experts elle a été pré fêtes
elle a été chef d'entreprise voilà elle
est des chefs d'entreprise a été haut
fonctionnaire elle a été pré fait elle
était directrice de cabinet d'un
ministre à l'été mini l'umq est là elle
est expérimentée elle est de gauche
indiscutablement et c'est un peu sale
cd1d termes de l'équation elle a servi
lionel jospin elle a toujours été de
gauche en fait ne se cache pas de ses
engagements elle dit qu'elle fait partie
des grands brûlés de 2002 notamment elle
un parcours républicain on oublie de le
dire elle et son père est immigré donc
c'est un homme un modèle du parcours
français
c'est une femme c'est la deuxième chef
de gouvernement femmes en france premier
ministre quand vous regardez la zone
pays européens en suède en islande en
finlande enfin que sais-je en estonie en
allemagne pendant d'aider plusieurs
années donc et puis et puis sur un des
sujets majeurs vous venez d'en parler un
des enjeux majeurs ii du quinquennat
l'environnement elle était
indiscutablement
compétente et expérimentée
non pas seulement parce qu'elle en a été
la ministre mais parce qu'elle a été la
directrice de cabinet du ministre le
roman ségolène royal donc elle sait de
quoi elle parle donc voilà je les
l'équation alors peut-être que s'il n'y
a pas surpris sur mondiaux s'y attendait
ça mais le problème n'est pas tellement
d'être surpris le problème est de savoir
si on va avoir matignon quelqu'un qui
est capable de conduire la politique du
gouvernement de manière sérieuse et elle
a l'air de remplir le jeu vous avez
s'est déroulé l'argumentaire mais ma
question c'est est plutôt en creux ce
que c'est aussi ça représente pour
emmanuel macron ca dans les équilibres
du
duo de l'exécutif on sera permettent
voilà on sélectionne le prêt à l'appui
que ça va lui permettre de continuer de
prendre quand même beaucoup lu il ya
simplement le président de la république
c'est qu'on sait depuis le quinquennat
ans déjà on est dans un peut-être que le
cajac blick le complétera mais on est
dans un régime semi présidentiel dans
lequel il y avait de toute façon à un
primat du présent d'un public mais
depuis le quinquennat le premier
ministre est devenu sinon le
collaborateur du président de la
république comme l'avait dit nicolas
sarkozy à propos de françois fillon mais
en tout cas n'a plus du tout la marge de
jeux et l'autonomie qui existait avant
les rapports se sont déséquilibrés en
faveur du président d'un public et donc
oui c'est vrai que mettre désormais un
premier ministe etc ni qui est chargé
d'exécuter efficacement la politique du
gouvernement ça paraît un choix que
emmanuel macron n'est pas le seul à
faire benjamin morel c'est effectivement
la lettre de la constitution
même s'il ya quelques quelques
subtilités et l usage renforcée depuis
le passage au quinquennat c'est surtout
l'usagé parce qu'en droit en fait le
présent la république assez peu de poids
si les pouvoirs d'exception le vrai
pouvoir est notamment administratifs et
j'y reviendrai il est à matignon est
donc comment marche notre régime en
réalité celui qui tient l'elysée par le
jeu du quinquennat et du truchement du
calendrier électoral tient la majorité
parlementaire celui qui tient le palais
bourbon tiens matignon et donc si vous
tenez l'elysée vous tenez l'ensemble des
pouvoirs donc il vous faut quelqu'un à
matignon qui tiennent deux choses en
réalité et c'est toute la force et la
limite peut-être du profil d'elisabeth
il faut quelqu'un qui tiennent
l'administration parce que le coeur
névralgique de l'administration
française il n'est pas à l'elysée lise
snpm il est à matignon et donc vous avez
besoin de quelqu'un qui connaisse cette
administration sache la maîtriser et
sachent articuler les différentes
politiques publiques elisabeth borne à
un profil excellent elle était à
l'équipement est là était préfète elle a
été chef de cabinet donc elles
maîtrisent notamment les enjeux qui
peuvent être relatifs à la planification
écologique etc elle saura mener cette
bataille ensuite un premier mise c'est
également quelqu'un qui tient la
majorité parlementaire parce que le
président n'a pas le droit de mettre un
orteil à l'assemblée nationale il peut
aller au congrès le réunir on connaît ça
mais à l'assemblée nationale pour tenir
sa majorité il ne peut pas être présent
vous avez donc besoin de quelqu'un qui
est là au cul âgées vous avez besoin de
quelqu'un qui est bien c'est marié les
différentes sensibilités de la majorité
la grande difficulté d'elisabeth board
c'est qu'elle n'a pas un profil
politique elle n'a jamais été élu elle
n'a jamais été parlementaire elle n'a
jamais été chef de groupe et cetera donc
ça peut représenter une difficulté ça va
être là dessus que probablement elle va
être jugés dans les prochaines semaines
mené cette campagne législative elle si
on sait bien qu emmanuel macron sera en
première ligne et ensuite tenir cette
majorité qui peut être relativement
problématique ensuite sur cour elisabeth
bornes vous avez un enjeu qui va être un
enjeu de mise en visibilité parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle n'apporte pas grand
chose étant donné qu'elle est là depuis
2010 est donc pour emmanuel macron il
faut arriver à faire exister autre chose
vous voyez qu'il y avait une forme de
complémentarité avec jean castex dans
quelle mesure il peut y avoir une
complémentarité avec elisabeth bornes ça
ça va être à elle d'y répondre dans les
prochaines semaines de
négociations d'abord c'est vrai que
depuis le quinquennat mais même avant la
majorité quand même fabriqué tenu à
organiser une fois qu'on en dise par le
président un public et par ses équipes
ac c'est vrai que matignon joue un rôle
mais depuis le quinquennat 1re - moi
j'ai connu le matignon
sous françois mitterrand
et le bleu matignon le président le
général de gaulle disait il ne peut pas
y avoir de dyarchie au sommet de l'état
pour bien montrer des délais dès le
départ que le président de la république
avait un rôle supérieure à toute autre
mais matignon avait une marge de jeux
d'autonomie un rôle de conception
d'organisation et joué dans la majorité
un rôle qui s'est beaucoup diminué
depuis ce que le poids est remonté du
côté mer en revanche qu'une question est
devenue de plus en plus brûlante et on
l'a vu septennat au quinquennat après
quinquennat c'est la question de
l'efficacité de l'exécution des
politiques donc matignon n'est plus - un
lieu d'élaboration des projets mais
l'exigence de d'exécution est beaucoup
plus forte et donc on a maintenant des
profils à matignon de gens dont on pense
qu'ils seront capables d'exécuter
efficacement d'une napolitaine chassant
vous rejoignez à legnica
premier point c'est que depuis la
nomination puis l'élection d' emmanuel
macron 2017 vous avez quand même une
prise directe aujourd'hui de l'elysée
sur matignon on l'a vu notamment avec la
création de quelque chose qui n'existait
pas avant c'est à dire des
collaborateurs commun et donc des gens
qui aujourd'hui circule entre l'elysée
matignon et donc permettre cette prise
directe sur l'administration et ensuite
on parlait tout à l'heure de la majorité
parlementaire il ya une différence par
exemple avec l'époque de nicolas sarkozy
vous aviez une majorité parlementaire
qui était bien organisée notamment à
l'époque par jean françois copé
aujourd'hui vous n'avez personne à
l'assemblée qui organise réellement bien
cette majorité des ja richard ferrand
mais il est président de l'assemblée et
c'est loin d'être aussi évident que
sarkozy c'était la droite c'était à
particules est exactement mais
exactement du d'exactement
n'existait pas exactement encore
aujourd'hui c'est parce que ça s'appelle
renaissance que ça existe l'ancrage
territorial ne s'invente pas et le temps
aussi l'expérience en politique la
discipline parlementaire et la capacité
ajustements jongler avec une majorité et
des desiderata parlementaire ça c'était
le rôle d'edouard philippe c'était le
rôle de jean castex ça va devoir devenir
celui d'elisabeth baume est ici à
l'accueil médiatique vous avez gt1
mais pas si grognon finalement non mais
c'est pas du tout grognon pourquoi parce
que depuis trois semaines le nom
d'elisabeth borne était sorti donc
finalement je vais vous dire tomates
dans les rédactions c'est la déception
parce qu'on adore ce feuilleton qu'on
est grognon ce feuilleton de suspense ce
qui va sortir du chapeau emmanuel macron
qui nous a habitués à tant de surprises
il y avait beaucoup de bienveillance
pour emmanuel macron il faut le dire du
milieu du milieu journalistique est donc
bon il avait deux bornes on l'a entendu
il ya depuis trois semaines et donc
cette hypothèse fini par se confirmer il
y avait quand même ce petit suspense
avec avec catherine vautrin qui
apparemment a dans la même lutte
politique mais non mais aurait duré
jusqu'au dernier moment voyez-vous et
puis finalement bon on se dit
effectivement ce que vous avez dit ici
c'est une technicienne compétente elle
connaissait dossier elle n'a jamais été
élu mais elle nageait mettez lui mais
elle a quand même expérimenté assez la
politique pour à ce poste être
compétente et ça fait partie évidemment
de ces défis des prochaines semaines
puisqu'elle se présente je vous le
rappelle dans le calvados le dans le
cadre de ces législatives
laure salvaing vous avez évaluer la cote
d'avenir d'elisabeth bornes c'était
début au début de ce mois au
le 5 mai alors il était à quel niveau
alors comme de nombreux ministres 1 et 2
personnes et est politique on évalue
dans notre baromètre pour le figaro
magazine la cote d'avenir des
personnalités politiques c'est à dire
qu'on demande aux français s'ils
souhaitent que à l'avenir ces
personnalités politiques jouent un rôle
ou pas en france et on a vu juste après
l'élection de d'emmanuel macron quand on
a commencé justement à parler
d'elisabeth bande et bien qu'elle a fait
un bond de 8 points dans notre baromètre
ans vivant à 21% des français qui
souhaitaient le voir jouer un rôle à
l'avenir en france donc on voit bien
quand même que même si elle n'était pas
connue quelque part elle n'est pas
considérée comme totalement illégitime
elle est plutôt crédible 1 21% une ccc
ccc ducation difficile la cote d'avenir
1 c'est beaucoup plus aux 21% c'est
plutôt un bon score c'est plutôt un bon
score aujourd'hui
celui qui est en haut du panier je
dirais c'est edouard philippe qui était
aux alentours or ça dépend des mois mais
voilà aux alentours de 40 43 pour cinq
stades ont envoyé 21 % c'est pas des
honorables et c'est plutôt excepté un
bon score et c'était d'ailleurs sais pas
si on a le graphique mais si on regarde
la ventilation en fonction des d
appartenance ou des sympathies aux
partis politiques parce qu'on entend
beaucoup dire c'est une femme de gauche
accédera je pense que elle est perçue
comme une femme de gauche parcelles par
ceux et celles qui la connaissent en
fait par le grand public finalement on
voit qu'elle a autant de soutiens à
droite qu'à gauche et surtout au sens
donc finalement elle est perçue comme
avant tout une ministre de macron pas
forcément une femme de droite peut
forcément une une femme de gauche à
s'équilibrer d'un point de vue politique
et ça peut être aussi un atout notamment
dans la conduite de raifort un petit peu
technique et accomplisse justement c'est
là où on voit que ce régime est hyper
présidentialiser parce qu'elle a quand
même elle a quand même mené la réforme
sncf 37 semaines de grève ça tous les
français ont été impactés d'une manière
ou d'une autre c'est elle qui
l'incarnait et finalement on se rend
compte qu'elles ne restent pas que les
français on compte bien compris que
c'était manuel macron qui voulait faire
cette réforme on lui impute pas cette
réforme c'est grève et comme la réforme
aussi de l'assurance chômage on pourra
dire oui mais c'est elisabeth bornes qui
nous enlève du pouvoir d'achat qui nous
on aime ses droits
finalement outre les syndicats qui eux
bien sûr était en négociations directes
avec sept ministres les français encore
une fois c'est emmanuel macron qu'il
désigne comme étant le responsable de
ces réformes donc on voit bien là pour
qu'on ait les critiques de la
duplicité parce que la critique sur vos
très critique sur la sncf c'est fabien
roussel qui l'a comparé à margaret
thatcher et la critique sur le chômage
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui dit elle a
fait là mais l'affairé ye un million de
français des minutes leur jeu
mais pour les français non ce n'est pas
à mon avis ce n'est pas si long et si on
les sens je pense que ces réformes était
moins impopulaire qu'on le prétend
peut-être que il y avait une minorité de
gens qui est notamment est tout à fait
légitimement ceux dont les intérêts
étaient directement affectés les
cheminots qui concernait que la réforme
de la sncf était critiquable mais pense
qu'une majorité de français
considéraient que cette réforme était
légitime de la même manière pour la
chance chômage sans doute moins
populaire comment les formes mais enfin
je prends je parle pas du fond mais je
pense que dans l'opinion publique l'idée
qu'il faille réformer notre système
d'assurance chômage n'était pas
complètement impopulaire donc c'est
peut-être aussi ça qui fait qu'elle est
passé à travers les gouttes c'est
qu'elle a conduit des réformes qui était
qui reconnaît un certain degré de
l'approbation d'un brel sur son poids
politique
aujourd'hui on est prête peu de poids
politique mais elle peut aussi se le
créent à matignon on disait un peu la
même chose d'edouard philippe pour début
de son mandat le l'espace politique qui
seul est clairement créé il se les crée
alors est prêt il se les crée dans une
condition un peu particulière c'est à
dire qu'on a un emmanuel macron qui
était lui au centre gauche en 2017 et
finalement il a besoin d'une partie du
centre droit et edouard philippe incarne
ce passage d'une partie du centre droit
en macro ni et donc il incarne quelque
chose il amène avec lui des électeurs
pour avoir du poids politique vous avez
trois solutions soit vous incarnez
quelque chose dans l'opinion par vous
même nicolas hulot et c'est à vous êtes
une figure médiatique et donc si vous
partez on peut craindre que et bien vous
départ soit problématique soit vous
apportez des élus auquel cas vous avez
une minorité au sein du groupe
parlementaire war une majorité vous avez
des élus locaux etc si vous partez ils
partiront avec vous et donc ça créera un
schisme ou bien vous apportez des
électeurs vous incarnez une tendance
électorale et c'est tout le revers d'un
profil très consensuel comme celui
d'elisabeth baume tout cas ton sensuel
au moins en macro ni c'est que eh bien
elle la porte ni elle n'enlève
profondément des lecteurs donc pour le
coup ça lui donne une marge de manoeuvre
et une marge de négociation et au
président de la république est
évidemment assez limité pourtant on va
l'écouter hier lors de la passation
pouvoir elle se elle revendique son
parcours de gauche on écoute la première
ministre je voudrais dire à quel point
j'ai apprécié de travailler à tes côtés
pendant ses 22 mois alors nous avons
évidemment des différences mais je pense
que nous avons aussi beaucoup de choses
en commun même si nous venons de
familles politiques différentes
je pense que nous sommes également
attachés à l'intérêt général à la
cohésion de notre pays à l'égalité des
chances et ça j'ai pu le mesurer
notamment dans les projets que nous
avons porté ensemble pour la jeunesse
denis olivennes est ce qu'elle peut
elisabeth bourne incarné ce courant de
gauge là ma chronique et voilà qui a eu
du mal à exister pendant pendant cinq
ans plus que ça même parce qu'on a
désormais un champ politique tripler en
trois pôles on a une droite qui s'est
radicalisée sur des thèmes identitaires
avec ces mots marine le pen et on a vu
que les républicains avaient fondu au
chaud soleil on a une gauche qui s'est
radicalisée sur des thèmes d'anti
libéralisme économique et on a vu que le
ps a fondu au soleil au profit de l efi
et on a au centre désormais une force de
gouvernement qui réunit le centre gauche
et le centre droit jusqu'à présent
emmanuel là qu'on ne pourra plus
incarner lui était le en même temps donc
la prochaine fois il veut pas se
représenter donc qui va incarner qui va
être le leader de cette force est ce que
ce sera un leader venus du centre droit
ou est ce que ce sera un leader ou
dinner venus du centre gauche jusqu'à
présent vous voyez pas émerger deux
leaders venus du centre gauche peut-être
que l as et sa cote d'avenir peut-être
qu'elle a cette capacité
et dans ce cas là non seulement elle
elle sera capable de fédérer la gauche
du maquereau nisme si j'ose dire mais
même de ramener la gauche de l'autre
rive celle qui n'a pas rejoint emmanuel
macron et qui pourrait s'associer les
socialistes disons qu'ils sont hostiles
à l'alliance avec elle et fit donc on
peut parfaitement imaginer demain qu'
elle soit l'un des candidats potentiels
à la succession de mâcon je dis ça on va
voir les les mois qui qui qui viennent
et comment tout ça ce se déroule mais
elle a cette capacité
je pense qu'il ya un autre point aussi
c'est à la elle n'incarne pas
effectivement pour le moment en tout cas
une force politique très clair en tout
cas elle incarne la féminité tout c'est
une femme ça fait 30 ans que qu'on
n'avait pas eu très peu d'autres femmes
chefs d'état dans l'espace européen
peuvent voilà montrer montrer l'exemple
elle en a parlé aussi d'ailleurs dans
son discours d'investiture faut pas
oublier qu emmanuel macron et ça on le
voit bien dans notre baromètre depuis
quelques mois là il a un problème
d'adhésion chez les femmes il ya dix
points de différence entre les hommes et
les femmes et les femmes ont de plus en
plus de mal à adhérer à son action
notamment parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
femmes aussi qui ont des petits salaires
qui souffrent de d'inégalité en tout cas
d'un sentiment d'inégalité dans la
société française et donc elisabeth
bornes elle peut aussi peut-être
justement incarner toute cette partie de
la population en fait les femmes tout
simplement alors justement sur cette
thématique
laetitia vous avez vous voulez revenir
sur les réactions du monde politique sur
sa qualité de femme sur sa qualité de
femme s'était relativement univoque
quand on écoutait les uns et les autres
les unes et les autres ce matin sur les
radios les ondes les télévisions tout le
monde salue finalement le fait que ce
soit une femme qui soit nommé à matignon
tant mieux à même si certains hommages
c'est vrai le sont un peu moins sont un
peu moins enthousiaste soit effet
peut-être avec des dents serrées un peu
de fiel même on va écouter eric zemmour
par exemple sur rtl ce matin
salue l'arrivée du nouveau premier
ministre que ce soit un homme ou une
femme si elle est compétent quand j'ai
toujours dit ça pendant toute la
campagne
je vois très bien le coup politique
derrière tout cela vous l'appelez
nouveau premier ministre ou dita
première ministre
enfin à l'autre à l'oreille mais vous
savez le français pour moi je dois
d'abord être beau donc oui c'est le
nouveau premier ministre bon ça fait
trop malin pour eric zemmour de dire
premier ministre c'est pas si grave
thomas pourquoi ce n'est pas si grave
parce qu on est en plein dans ce que
gramsci l'italien politologue philosophe
avait théorisé c'est à dire qu'on est
dans une bataille culturelle que la
politique était à la remorque de la
société et que la société a bousculé la
politique et que l'idée d'une femme à
matignon va devenir on espère commune et
puis quand on en parlera plus dans 20 ou
30 ans est d'ailleurs edith cresson
celle qu'on a appelé la pompadour celle
que les médias ont surnommé matignon
c'est elle qui l'a dit dès dimanche dans
le jdd et l'a répété l a dit la société
est beaucoup moins machiste que ne l'est
la classe politique donc oui deux tiers
des français plébiscitent est une femme
à matignon et donc emmanuel macron a
finalement entendu aussi un peu les
français et puis arraisonné que son
époque emmanuel macron jeune président
quand même qui par deux fois a eu
l'occasion de nommer une femme jamais
fait là c'était vraiment impossible de
passer à côté et comme le disait cécile
duflot ce matin sur france info même si
dans la presse on parle quand même un
peu aujourd'hui aussi de la couleur de
la veste d'elisabeth bornes sa
nomination est une victoire son bien et
je vois elisabeth bande depuis de
nombreuses années qu'elle fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour justement ne pas donner
prise à des débats mais en fait quoi que
fasse une femme en la matière de toute
façon il ya toujours matière à
commentaire est donc la seule chose qui
fera que ça va s'arrêter c'est qu'il y
aura de plus en plus de femmes première
ministre et puis j'espère un jour de
femmes présidentes enfin que ça
deviendra un normal finalement parce que
ça c'est encore considéré comme un
événement voilà la bataille culturelle
dont je vous parlais à l'instant
évidemment quand on regarde les états
unis avec la nomination de la nouvelle
porte-parole karin jean-pierre une femme
noire et lesbiennes on a encore un tout
petit peu de chemin à faire mais bon
c'est vrai qu'aux états unis aussi le
droit à l'avortement est menacée donc
vous voyez c'est un combat finalement
c'est un vrai combat je le crois
vraiment qu'il ne faut pas lâcher et ne
tombons pas dans le cliché parce que je
vous ai entendus les uns et les autres
mais vous n'êtes pas les seuls à dire
oui mais finalement la france était
vraiment la dernière en europe regardez
ce qui s'est passé autour de nous
vraiment non ce n'est pas vraiment vrai
je vous invite à lire le tweet d'une
journaliste politique de 20 minutes qui
s'est amusé comme ça dans les régimes
actuels n'est pas remontée sur les 50
dernières années a compté le nombre de
femmes pour le poste de premier ministre
par rapport au nombre d'hommes et par
exemple en allemagne bien sûr qu'un gala
merkel a régné pendant 16 ans mais c'est
la seule femme sur neuf premier ministre
en angleterre on parle tous deux à chuck
il ya 40 ans mais il y a que deux femmes
sur 77 donc vous voyez bien que le ratio
la parité est encore loin loin d'être
acquise denis olivennes jeu hier j'ai
démarré le débat en posant cette
question et je m'en suis un peu voulu
après parce que finalement ce n'est pas
le plus important si vous êtes d'accord
avec cette idée le fait que eliza être
board soit une femme est nommé à
matignon
est-ce que je suis d'accord avec l'idée
que c'est pas le plus important
bah c'est pas le plus important j'ai
fait la liste de toutes les qualités
qu'elle avait et un jour françoise
giroud avait dit on sera vraiment
féministe le jour on ne voit une femme
incompétente à un poste parce qu'en
effet pour que nos pour que les femmes
soient nommés à des postes dans cet
univers pas seulement l'univers de la
politique l'univers des entreprises
aussi il faut qu'elle soit bien plus
compétentes sinon elles sont elles sont
immédiatement arrêtés soit trajectoire
donc mais je donc je gèle a bien
d'autres qualités qui justifie qu'elle
occupe ce poste je trouve que c'est
quand même important qu'on ait une femme
première ministre
cdh setting c'est incroyable que on s'en
étonne encore mais oui c'est ça je veux
dire mais ça sera oui mais
réjouissons-nous la réaction
réjouissons-nous tout de même je pense
que tant que je sais pas du tout que
c'est pas la discrimination positive
mais tant qu'on n'aura pas d'une parité
légitime dans tous les jobs y compris
politiques il faudra qu'on continue de
ceux de se réjouir de ce qu'une femme et
un poste auquel elle évidemment le droit
évidemment leur salle va être
effectivement ça c'est ce que dit edith
cresson depuis depuis longtemps et
qu'elle a redit à l'occasion de la
nomination
d'elizabeth board est effectivement là
politique la classe politique est en
retard sur la société française sur ces
questions en tout cas ce qu'on voit
effectivement dans nos données c'est que
la classe politique et puis une partie
des français aussi quand même malgré
tout à fait être en retard et on parlait
de l'allemagne veut pas que les français
aussi l'allemagne c'est très étonnant en
allemagne par exemple on a une étude
donc dans plusieurs pays qui montre
effectivement à quel point on aime ou
pas à l'aise avec l'idée d'un chef
d'état femme bun en allemagne ils sont
beaucoup moins à l'aise avec cette idée
que les françaises quand même assez tard
le statut les jeunes et notamment les
jeunes hommes sont moins à l'aise que
les que les femmes avec cette idée
d'avoir un je-ne-sais-quoi jeunes c'est
au moins de 35 ans et s'est même les
plus jeunes c'est plutôt 18 24 ans est
quand même intéressant que les jeunes
hommes aujourd'hui soit mois sont moins
à l'aise avec cette idée d'une femme
chef d'état donc je pense
qu'effectivement dans la classe
politique c'est vrai qu'il ya ce retard
je dirais aussi dans les entreprises et
vous avez raison de le préciser parce
que c'est pas important en soit
effectivement que ce soit une femme ce
qui est important c'est le symbole tout
simplement on va effectivement ont
discuté pendant un petit moment et on va
discuter de la couleur de sa veste
certainement et 2 et 2 qui garde les
enfants voilà mai mais ce qui est
important c'est le symbole que ça donne
aux français c'est c'est ce qu'elle dit
d'ailleurs dans son discours là ça donne
un signe aussi à un signe des sports au
physique ici finalement c'est c'est
possible et j'espère que très vite on
arrêtera de commenter en effet le fait
que ce soit une femme pour commenter
plus tôt ses actions et ses réalisations
alors on attend maintenant la
composition je pense que steve jourdain
doit être prêts à nous rejoindre la
composition
bonsoir steve gouvernement resserré
promis par emmanuel macron quand vous
dire j'ai l'impression d'avoir déjà
entendu ça fruits gouvernement resserré
gouvernement compact au gouvernement de
combat il ya plusieurs variantes 1 à la
formule et peu importe la couleur
politique droite centre gauche c'est
presque toujours la même petite musique
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
ce gouvernement sera efficace il sera
utile est garanti sans gras tenait
écouter emmanuel macron le candidat
emmanuel macron c'était le 12 mars 2010
est sur le plateau de tf1 je vais nommer
un premier ministre et un gouvernement
ce gouvernement
progressiste ce gouvernement de réforme
je constituerai un gouvernement 2 15
membres maximum très ramassé avec des
personnes de la société civile et des
personnes du monde politique venant de
la gauche du centre de la droite voilà
quinze membres maximum je vous laisse
juger le gouvernement castex dernière
version comporte et 41 membres c'est
beaucoup beaucoup même à l'échelle macro
à titre de comparaison l'équipe
d'edouard philippe avait terminé son
bail avec 36 portefeuille beaucoup plus
sain que ce que promettait donc le
candidat macron wim emmanuel macron
n'est pas le seul alors au nom non ils
ont tous fait nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande pour ne citer qu en
fait bien depuis une vingtaine d'années
tous les présidents veulent mettre les
gouvernements au régime sec il faut nous
dit-on réduire les dépenses de l'état
lorsqu'il faut savoir thomas sait que le
budget de fonctionnement d'un
gouvernement c'est vraiment pas beaucoup
si l'on compte les ministres les
secrétaires d'état les collaborateurs on
arrive au total à 160 millions d'euros
l'année dernière c'était le cas pour le
gouvernement castex ça correspond à
moins de
0,05 pour cent du budget de l'état alors
je sais ce que vous allez me dire un
euro c'est un euro et quand on est
président et bien faut montrer qu'on ne
gaspille pas l'argent des français oui
mais il ya quand même un pays de 67
millions d'habitants à gouverner et
quand ce ne sont pas les ministres qui
gouverne et bien ce sont les
ministration où les hauts fonctionnaires
en gros ministre ou administrateurs il
faut choisir bref il ya des dépenses
quasi incompressible s il ya des
présidents qui ont effectivement
gouverner avec des équipes resserrées
oui sous la moyenne sous la vème
république c'est
33,9 ninis le gouvernement debré était
composée de seulement vingt six membres
celui de lionel jospin s'était aussi 26
membres le record du gouvernement le
plus rose serré est détenue par le
gouvernement fillon s'était 19 membres
seulement pour la première équipe fillon
ça va durer seulement un mois entre mai
et juin 2007 c'est à dire entre
l'élection présidentielle et les
élections législatives c'est un peu ce
que emmanuel macron visiblement à en
tête bref si on résume elle commence
parfois bien les promesses du
gouvernement resserré et finit souvent
mal merci steve est ce que c'est pas
benjamin morel une fausse polémique
cette histoire là parce que de toute
façon il faut des équipes et il faut il
faut des équipes parfois nombreuses pour
bien administrer un pays c'est
totalement une fausse polémique pour le
coup c'est un peu une marotte
d'éditorialistes et les gouvernements se
donnent comme mission de réduire le
nombre de membres de leur gouvernement
mais en réalité ça ne sert à rien et
c'est même contre productif tout
bêtement parce que en fait l'arbitrage
il est simple vous avez deux membres du
gouvernement plus vous pouvez quadrillé
l'administration la contrôler lorientais
avec l'administration et mal
intentionnées mais si elle n'est pas
guidé et ben forcément elle a en roue
libre vous avez besoin d'une impulsion
politique et pour ça vous avez besoin
d'un membre du gouvernement en même
temps si vous avez trop de membres du
gouvernement vous avez des compétences
qui s'enchevêtrent et s'est du coup
difficile ça multiplie les arbitrages et
ça peut créer à matignon et à l'elysée
un certain nombre de difficultés donc
faut arriver à trouver cet équilibre cet
équilibre là le record c'est le
gouvernement rocard avec 48 membres cet
équilibre il peut se retrouver il peut
se trouver à une trentaine de membres
c'est loin d'être scandaleux or
justement on essaye toujours de
rationaliser en tendant à moins c'est
une mauvaise idée on l'a également fait
au début du précédent quinquennat le
quinquennat de manuel maquereau en 2017
en réduisant le nombre de membres des
comptes des cabinets mystérieux la
circulaire philippe limitait à dix le
nombre de membres du cad des cabinets
mystérieux pareil en réalité vous coupez
le ministre de son administration et du
coup vous expliquer beaucoup des
difficultés des ministres au début du
quinquennat par cette incapacité à
dialoguer avec leur administration
donc bref cet argent là est bien c'est
de l'argent bien employé parce que c'est
l'argent qui permet justement bien
l'équipe benjamins - cette obsession
tout d'où vient cette obsession on a
sondé français il on aurait dit dans la
grande majorité que c'était trop
d'où ça vient je parle sous le contrôle
de
contrôle mais je pense pas qu'on ait
sombré l'avancé sur ce sujet mais quand
est ce qu'on va faire des économies
je suis assez d'accord je pense que ce
que veulent les français c'est
effectivement que le gouvernement et que
l'état d'une manière générale soit
exemplaire ne gaspille pas les finances
publiques mais il n'y a pas de sujet
spécifique sur les ministres et les
français savent bien que des ministères
on peut s'en sont des gros ministère est
de plus en plus ce sont deux des gros
ministères avec des portefeuilles très
important nécessite un certain nombre de
collaborateurs il ya vraiment pas quand
on interroge les français de polémique
là-dessus mais je pense que c'est
l'image qu'on se fait effectivement des
ministres d'une équipe un petit peu trop
importante et de l'image que ça peut
donner alex tai c'est l'image
expérience je crois que ça vient aussi
d'un autre sujet c'est que vous êtes je
ne partage absolument votre point de vue
si vous avez moins de ministres c'est le
pouvoir donné à la technostructure dont
je suis issue donc je tire une balle
dans mon propre pied mais s'ils
appellent les ministères les ministres
sont là pour exercer un contrôle
politique - vous avez deux ministres
l'administration est puissante mais il
ya un autre sujet c'est que si vous avez
beaucoup de ministres la demie le clou
l'administration est bien quadrillé mais
les conflits est ce les arbitrages les
difficultés les problèmes de frontières
les frottements et les couacs sont plus
nombreux et donc ça demande une énergie
d'arbitrage michel rocard a une
expression magnifique est d'ailleurs
très vrai il disait maintenions c'est le
terminal des emmerdes c'est à dire que
matignon mais isabelle bird va le bâlois
maintenant c'est landreau on remonte les
couacs les difficultés les combles et
conflits donc si vous avez beaucoup de
ministères vous avez beaucoup de
conflits mais c'est vrai regret est que
à la fin des fins il est mieux et même
plus démocratique de gérer des conflits
parce que ce sont des contradictions
d'intérêt légitime le ministère de
l'environnement ou bercy où j'ai
économisé le ministère de l'intérieur
s'oppose au ministère de la justice et
chacun un point de vue et l'arbitrage
est sain s'il est transparent donc il
vaut mieux à mon sens gérer des
arbitrages et des conflits que laisser
l'administration en roue libre sans
contrôle politique du point de vue de la
démocratie c'est vrai mais l'arbitrage
se fait de plus en plus à l'elysée et
c'est l'une des difficultés d'ailleurs y
compris entre administrations
déconcentrées et administrations
centrales aujourd'hui et on le disait
tout à l'heure l'elysée n'a pas les
moyens d'assurer tous ses arbitrages et
c'est également l'une des difficultés
pas seulement du dernier quinquennat
mais en fait des trois derniers mais à
vous entendre personne ne parle de du
scandale mckinsey alors que l on peut
considérer que c'est lié à ce que avoir
une administration avoir une équipe
importante avant une équipe compétente
très bien mais encore faut-il lui faire
suffisamment confiance et peut-être ne
pas par un geste-réflexe faire appel à
un cabinet extérieur bêtement exactement
ne pas avoir de geste réflexe est de
connaître cette administration est à
dire que dès le moment où vous avez un
cabinet ministériel qui au début du
quinquennat était uniquement assigné à
des tâches de communication vous avez un
ministre qui ne connaît pas son
administration il est beaucoup plus
facile d'avoir un recours extérieur
plutôt que justement sonder les
compétences qui existent qui sont au
fond de la technostructure pour ensuite
les faire remonter c'est l'une des
difficultés est en effet là dessus il va
falloir prendre conscience des atouts
quoi notre administration aujourd'hui
alors ça va juste sur ma kiné je pense
que c'est c'est aussi le même débat la
plupart des français se moquent que
l'état où le gouvernement fasse appel à
des cabinets spécialisés parce qu'il ya
des sujets très techniques qui nécessite
une technicité spécifiques se justifier
si c'est justifié si c'est un rapport
dont on se poser on sur l'intérêt
équivaut 400000 euros gens lisent par la
fenêtre oui c'est ça mais sur cette
affaire macky disais on a un peu sonder
l'opinion mais aussi en fait ceux qui
étaient les plus mécontents c'étaient
ceux qui étaient les plus politisés
finalement les français non politisée
quelqu'un dise c'est la cuisine interne
c'est la cuisine a
effectivement c'est pas c'est pas un
sujet et je pense que vous avez raison
qu'on dise que c'est surtout un sujet
politique de pouvoir finalement garder
ses troupes et contrôler ses troupes
parce que plus on a un ministère
important enfin nous des ministres en
nombre important finalement c'est
difficile de contrôler tout le monde
j'ai pu pour terminer sur cette
thématique de
la taille on va dire de ce gouvernement
denis olivennes c'est aussi une alchimie
complexe politiquement il faut il faut
différentes familles politiques il faut
la parité il faut les régions françaises
il est tout ça explique aussi peut-être
alors pas entre une présidence et jusque
là si on le sait bien mais en mai mais
le fait que la taille du gouvernement
grandissent quoi c'est pour ça que moi
je m'amuse quand je vois les
commentaires que nous allons tous ca a
posteriori sur la composition gandhi se
trouve que j'ai assisté dans le bureau
de pierre bérégovoy premier ministre est
à la composition de son gouvernement il
est au téléphone avec le président de la
république et tout à coup il assomme de
hasard il crée le le bal personnes la
carte finale c'est complètement
incroyable ijan à l'époque on l'y ai
même eu un homonyme qui avait été nommé
la place d'un autre
quelqu'un est nommé avait une position
parce qu'il est compétent pays bas n'ont
ils moins qu'un breton pas fonder un
breton et le lendemain les commentaires
très avisé explique la rationalité de
ses choix lent que ces choix ont été
très aléatoire c'est un choix qui a
tellement de contraintes dans lequel en
effet ya tellement d'entrée politique
jean région compétences qu'au bout d'un
moment c'est on a rajouté pardon nous
intéresse mais on l'a évoqué hier donc
je passe rapidement là dessus mais la
question de la transparence avec
l'intervention de la hot wheels
transparence donc ok donc à la fin sous
les tout le passé fiscales et autres des
des futurs ministres est passé au crible
en ce moment à la fin ça ressemble bien
davantage un jeune bundhoo et une partie
d'échecs la composition événement quand
vous voulez une fois que vous l'avez vu
de près alors là vous vous riez ensuite
des commentaires avisés que nous allons
tous faire sur la rationalité qui sous
tend ces choix en attend tout cas ce
gouvernement
d'ici mercredi ou jeudi dernier délai
c'est ce qui a été dit aujourd'hui
conseil des ministres jeudi mais
emmanuel macron nous a
habitués dans pour d'autres équipes
gouvernementales à nous faire attendre
on verra bien je ferai campagne de la
planification écologique maintenant
expression empruntée par le présent la
république au candidat mélenchon qui
était pas le premier à l'employé
évidemment ce sera la priorité
d'elisabeth board c'est ce que ma belle
macro à citer en premier dans ce tweet
de bienvenue en quelque sorte cher
elisabeth bornes madame la première
ministre écologie c'est ce qu'il en
premier ensuite santé éducation plein
emploi renaissance démocratique europe
sécurité ensemble avec le nouveau
gouvernement nous continuerons d'agir
sans relâche pour les françaises et les
français
c'est une question je reste avec vous
denis olivennes parce que la question de
la transition écologique c'est quand
même une équation particulièrement
complexe il ya l'urgence tout le monde
en est conscient il ya l'acceptabilité
par les français c'est pas si simple
notamment pour
les nouvelles énergies
les éoliennes est ce le sera pour les
projets de réacteurs nucléaires lancé
par le président la république dans
l'équation il ya les entreprises le
medef vient de demander baisse des
impôts pouvoir encaisser le choc de
cette transition qui on le sait un
coûtera cher bref il faut une volonté
politique très forte est-ce que vous
pensez que le président de république à
cette volonté politique peut-être pour
laisser sa trace dans l'histoire
je pense qu'il a pas de choix surtout il
ils expriment ils incarnent il lit la
souhaitait être par rapport à aux deux
forces disons populiste le parti de la
modernisation du pays et on sait
désormais pour tous les pays occidentaux
par tuer mais pas seulement que la
question du rhône de relever le défi
climatique et de la biodiversité et une
avec une question majeure et qu'elle est
en effet pas facile et elle est d'autant
moins facile qu'au fond il ya deux voies
qui s'offrent
politiquement il ya celles qui est
soutenu par disons l'écologie radicale
qui en arrête tout la décroissance
l'austérité la sobriété et c'est une
voie qui est à mes yeux en tous les cas
et aux yeux de beaucoup
extraordinairement dangereuse parce
qu'elle va conduire à l'appauvrissement
et elle tue la croissance et donc elle
tu là
elle engendre l'appauvrissement non
seulement des pays occidentaux mais
dramatiquement des pays en voie de
développement donc l'autre voie beaucoup
plus difficile c'est la voie de la
modernisation et elle pose des problèmes
un peu de la nature de ce que nous avons
connu au moment des trente glorieuses en
tout cas des années 60 ça suppose
beaucoup d'investissements publics ça
suppose de la régulation étatique ça
suppose en effet de faire un arbitrage
entre les entreprises les ressources des
entreprises et sur des ménages ça
suppose
d'investir dans la recherche et la
technologie parce que cette voie là elle
fait l'hypothèse qui me paraît la seule
raisonnable que ces défis seront relevés
par notre capacité intellectuelle notre
capacité par l'innovation et l'invention
elle est là le bond technologique en
avant à relever ce défi ce qui est
possible mais ça ça suppose de mettre
une politique qui ne peut pas c'est pour
ça que la planification est tellement
importante emprunter ou pas à mélenchon
c'est que ce héros c'est cette action-là
ne peut être qu'une action comment
dirais-je nuit et suppose une
gouvernance suppose une action publique
s'est tournée on n'est pas du tout dans
un univers dans lequel on peut laisser
les entreprises à agir ce qui était vrai
sur d'autres secteurs là il faut qu' une
action publique pour orienter les
investissements pour orienter la
recherche pour orienter des ressources
et cette action publique non seulement
doit se faire à l'échelle des pays mais
elle doit même probablement se faire en
tout cas à l'échelle du continent donc
aucun gouvernement responsable
modernisateur progressiste très
formateur ne
éviter de se confronter à cette question
et donc je pense que qu'il le veuille ou
non sa volonté qu'il le veuille ou non
il doit le faire et c'est évidemment là
dessus probablement que l'histoire
jugera
rétrospectivement de son action alors on
a fait en ouverture de ce débat un bilan
de l'action d'elisabeth borne à matignon
il y rester un peu plus d'un an et
succéder à françois de rugy
sexe a pas forcément beaucoup marqué
l'opinion c'est d'ailleurs le paradoxe
peut être deux du bilan écologique des
manuels macron c'est à dire que ce qui
marque le plus l'opinion vous avez
peut-être me contredire mais c'est la
convention citoyenne pour le climat les
150 promesses et le fait que en tout cas
pour les citoyens qui ont participé elle
n'est pas été tenues est ce que est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
effectivement il ya une chaleur qui a eu
beaucoup de lois qui ont été votées il
ya eu beaucoup d'action menée et
notamment des lois qui incite les
entreprises à accélérer leur transition
et je pense que dans l'esprit des
français ce qui manque c'est le sens
donné à la politique énergétique c'est à
dire que ne comprennent pas exactement
vers où on va et comment on va y aller
c'est pour ça que je trouve que ce terme
de planification est très très bien
trouvée parce que justement en soit je
pense que ça peut être un levier
d'adhésion de la part de la part des
français c'est vrai que
grande majorité de français aujourd'hui
considèrent que les pouvoirs publics ne
font pas assez pour
l'environnement la transition écologique
et surtout n'auront pas forcément dans
le bon sens mais quel est ce sens déjà
il faudrait il faudrait répondre et puis
il ya autre chose aussi c'est qu'est ce
que vont faire les citoyens mais mais
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire et ça
c'est assez inquiétant parce que voyez
vous avez 6 français sur 10 qui nous
disent je n'ai pas les moyens
économiques de pouvoir lutter pour en
faveur de l'environnement en faveur
voilà d'une action sur sur la transition
écologique et ses six français sur dix
ils sont encore plus nombreux quand on
regarde les clés les couches populaires
donc il ya ce sentiment d'impuissance le
sentiment aussi que les responsables
sont les grands entreprises que les
premiers à devoir agir se sont grandes
entreprises responsables politiques mais
le citoyen et ça ça va être tout un
travail extrêmement je pense est
difficile pour la première ministre ça
va être justement de convaincre et
d'arriver à changer les comportements
des gens et qu'ils y trouvent un
bénéfice quel qu'il soit parce qu'on
voit bien que quand on
regarde les différents arguments
rationnels c'est pas finalement en
mettant en avant des arguments
rationnels que les gens acceptent de
changer de comportement et notamment
dans ce sujet de l'environnement et
l'écologie benjamin morel il ya eu un
appel lancé par un certain nombre de
personnalités jean marc jancovici en
tête pour une formation des ministres
aux questions environnementales de
protection de la biodiversité et de
lutte pour préserver le climat je sais
pas si vous avez la réponse à cette
question mais mais moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'il ya un retard de prise de
conscience malgré tout et qu'on ne
soupçonne pas forcément alors ça qui est
un retard de prise de conscience sekiya
je dirais une hiérarchisation des sujets
par les gouvernants qui aujourd'hui mais
pas forcément l'écologie en tête parce
que l'écologie à des reports électoraux
relativement faible en réalité et en
effet il peut y avoir une écologie des
petits gestes mais on a dépassé
l'écologie des petits gestes c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui je rejoins tout à
fait ce qui a été dit l'écologie doit
être une écologie de politiques
publiques simply de la planification ça
implique d' orienter les comportements
et les rendre possible rouler propre
c'est bien sympathique bon quand faut-il
en avoir les moyens et s'implique du
coup de revoir l'ensemble du réseau de
fourniture d'électricité etc bref c'est
de la politique publique
c'est quelque chose qui implique une
coordination entre les ministères et une
vraie volonté étatique le problème
vis-à-vis de ça c'est qu'il faut le
financer et ça va coûter très très cher
et le vrai défi et prochaines années il
va être là voyez que vous avez
aujourd'hui les banques centrales qui
sont en train de resserrer la vis on a
des taux d'intérêt qui augmente une
inflation qui augmentent également donc
du coup des banques centrales qui cesse
ou keira rifi l'argent le quantitative
easing et c'est donc pour arriver à
financer des grands projets de
transition tel que c'était envisagé il
va falloir trouver l'argent quelque part
pour l'instant c'est pas vraiment où
aller on va parler d'une polémique ce
nouveau gouvernement va trouver sur son
chemin
celle lancée par le maire europe
ecologie les verts de grenoble eric
piolle qui veut autoriser le burqini
dans les piscines de sa ville sa
proposition a été adoptée de justesse
hier 29 voix pour face à 27 voix contre
au sein du conseil municipal ça agace du
côté des alliés d'europe écologie les
verts écouter françois ruffin c'était
hier sur rtl pour la france insoumise
j'en ai vraiment rien à secouer alors
pourquoi le maire de grenay je fais ces
chocolats mais ce mois le règlement des
piscines piscine municipale à grenoble
si vous voulez quand jouer moi le
burqini ne sais pas est ce que le
burkina est aujourd'hui je suis
journaliste et moi je vous dis je vois
les esquives et quand même et je sais
pas que j'espère c'est que j'en ai rien
à secouer ce que je vous assure c'est
que quand je vois la situation le pays
mais la situation des gens dans mon coin
n'y a pas une seule personne qui va me
parler de vue du règlement des piscines
municipales de la ville de grenoble à
erik cole l'oubli se débrouille qu'ils
aient brouille ces problèmes laetitia
que pas ça vous inspire quoi le retour
énième retour de cette polémique écoutez
je pense que je vais garder ce sujet
elle envoyé à toutes les écoles mais
même pas de journalisme c'est à dire que
c'est du cynisme pur comment un homme
politique comme françois ruffin botte en
touche avec un cynisme une insolence
enfin en plus c'est complètement déplacé
sa réponse parce que il botte en touche
en disant finalement ça n'intéresse pas
les français qui sont obsédés par leurs
fins de mois c'est pas vrai voilà il
faut arrêter aussi avec ce pouvoir
d'achat qui voit là il yad'autres
d'autres sujets et évidemment que cette
porte ouverte c'est une porte ouverte on
le comprend bien cette autorisation du
burkini c'est aussi du cynisme de la
part d' eric piolle qui le fait à des
fins de stratégie politique donc pour
moi c'est honteux honteux on ne peut pas
laisser passer ce type de mesures sans
là pour le coup en discuter tous
ensemble il faut arrêter sur ça
n'intéresse pas les français et puis
finalement c'est rien c'est accessoire
c'est pas vrai que c'est pas vraiment
parlé de symbole tout à l'heure c'est un
symbole fort et je trouve que dalle par
direct violent encore une fois le
cynisme là on est vraiment à l'acmé du
cynisme donc vous dites cynisme à la
fois dans la réaction
légèreté de la réaction de françois
ruffin et dans le la celle d'eric de
livres humaine est ce que vous y voyez
une stratégie de la part d'eric yonne
parce que c'est quand même une musique
qu'il laisse dans le jardin de la
nouvelle union politique écologique et
sociale c'est si la laïcité férial il ya
un certain nombre de lignes de fracture
au sein de cette collégienne coalition
pardon la laïcité en est une très
importante avant de répondre à cette
question je parce qu'elle est éclairé
par le fonds le fonds moi je suis
évidemment profondément à titre
personnel hostiles non seulement aux
burkini mais aux voiles sont pas des
choses mais ce sont des c'est une
atteinte à l'égalité des entre les
hommes et les femmes parce que c'est une
âme qu'on impose à des femmes des ges de
pudeur qu'on n'impose pas aux hommes je
serai très favorable augure qui ni si
les hommes de elle portait aussi bon
mais une fois que j'ai dit ça je suis
dans un régime de démocratie libérale
auquel je suis profondément attachée et
sauf à ce que ce ces signes extérieurs
porte atteinte à un santon de d'éléments
que les juges à la fois nationaux et
européens ont rappelé il relève de la
liberté de chacun de se vêtir comme il
le souhaite ça me défrise mais c'est
comme ça donc je trouve que ce débat
autour du burqini à quelque chose de
l'incompréhensible autant je trouve que
la question de l'espace public de la
protection des espaces publics des
écoles des universités de
l'accompagnement des élèves est une
vraie question autant la liberté de
chacun de se vêtir ne me paraît pas
devoir faire l'objet d'un débat public
alors maintenant une fois que j'ai dit
ça je vois bien que beaucoup veulent en
faire un un point de clivage politique
les tenants du libéralisme culturel
extremis comme paul
veulent montrer à quel point ils sont
pardon ça va de fait puisque la burqa
est interdite dans l'espace public donc
déjà
exprimés oui c'est pas la même chose
non en fait d'un point de vue juridique
déjà c'est un problème de laïcité c'est
à dire que juridiquement la laïcité
c'est la neutralité du service public et
pas lunettes et de la neutralité des
usagers du service public ya une
exception c'est l'école on a dû faire
une loi il est par ailleurs s'est
justifiée et proportionnée parce que les
usagers sont mineurs là pour le coup on
ne fait pas passer lorsqu'on interdit la
le burkini dans les piscines le
l'interdiction sur le sou de la laïcité
on utilise comme argument et l'hygiène
publique c'est totalement hypocrite de
même pour la burqa la burqa en fait
pourquoi est elle interdite pour des
raisons d'ordre public parce qu'on
considère qu'en effet le fait de l'im
celle de dissimuler le visage pourrait
porter une atteinte à la sécurité
publique donc on n'est pas face
juridiquement à un problème de laïcité
si vous voulez interdire le burkini à ce
stade là il faut passer par une voie
détournée ce qui est ce sur quoi joue
eric piolle aujourd'hui ensuite je
nuancerais sur le côté cynique en
réalité parce que électoralement la
nuque n'y a aucun intérêt mais avec
l'électorat qui est sensible à cette
thématique là il est très concentré dans
cette dans certaines circonscriptions et
donc ces circonscriptions elles vous
seront dupes l'électorat qui pourrait
balancer entre la reine la nuque
l'abstention dans des circonscriptions
beaucoup plus charnière lui il est
plutôt sensible al'inverse à ce type de
polémique et donc lui au contraire il
parlait dans l'abstention ou voter la
reine en opposition donc en réalité la
sq est en train de faire eric piolle
s'est tiré une balle dans le pied oui de
l'alliance électorale donc à mon avis
beaucoup plus que du cynisme c'est pour
le coup de l'idéologie d'accord fait
plus grave elle est votre avis là-dessus
laure salvaing je remarque à rennes
burqini est autorisé dans les piscines
de la ville depuis 2000 18e il y avait
une polémique mais petite polémique
incomparable avec celle qui est en train
de naître je rappelle que le préfet de
l'isère a été à saisir le tribunal
administratif enfin bref on est on est
parti pour la polémique qui va occuper
sans doute les premières semaines de ces
de ces élections législatives comment
vous est ce que c'est le contexte
électoral qui explique ses réactions et
peut-être en filigrane le quai comment
les français réagissent face à cette
grave déjà le premier point je pense que
les français ne se moque pas de ce sujet
en effet on a près 70% des français qui
sont contre le port du burkini donc
c'est pas rien on aurait pu avoir 40%
des français s'en moque non ce n'est pas
le cas on associer 70% des français qui
sont contre et y compris à gauche y
compris les sympathisants de la nuque en
fait ils sont 58% à considérer
bah que c'est pas à ce que ce n'est pas
une bonne chose que le port du burkini
n'est pas une bonne chose donc
effectivement c'est pas forcément un
coût politique telle qu'on peut
l'entendre alors mais je pense que là on
est vraiment dans
le symbole ce que signifie effectivement
à la fois
cette volonté d'intégration d'une
population qui parfois se sent justement
rejeté etc et d'un autre côté les
partisans banc de droit peut être
supérieure à la législation
qu'on peut appeler des valeurs en fait
des valeurs d'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes et c'est vrai que ça a
beaucoup de français aussi et deux
françaises notamment qui considère
effectivement comme extrêmement
choquants qu' on soit obligé de se
cacher pour pouvoir accéder à une
piscine à ali mohamoud rapidement je
pense que culturellement la question se
pose c'est vrai que cette question est
une question qui nous qui nous
interpelle tous mais il ya quelque chose
qui est aussi important que les
vêtements un autre qui 90 dans notre
culture dans nos valeurs c'est que nous
sommes ceux qui avons créé là il est les
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et
déclaration aura nommé citoyen c'est
nous qui considérons que la liberté est
la règle et l'interdiction est
l'exception ça c'est la csn points elo
points 2 c'est que ceux qui jugent de ça
c'est le juge c'est les tribunes en un
état de droit et donc au lieu de faire
des polémiques politiques autour de ces
questions on doit les traiter comme une
démocratie libérale avancée en essayant
de protéger la liberté et de laisser le
juge le soin de trancher les litiges qui
nous sépare merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat denis
olivennes rappel le titre de votre livre
un étrange renoncement publié aux
éditions albin michel